[Music]
okay everybody i am so
thrilled today because i am joined by
sam richardson aka anik and ben schwartz
aka jasper in the after party just
coming apple tv plus this friday how you
guys doing today
yeah you're doing well good to see you
yes great to see you guys you guys look
great i'm excited to talk to you guys uh
sam i have to ask with the nieks episode
framed as this rom-com
was it always going to be a rom-com or
is there other genres you might have
actually explored for that
um well uh when i was when i read the
script it was a rom-com so i i'd always
known it as a rom-com and i i feel like
uh it matches anik's personality pretty
well in his sort of like
his storyline of trying to see if
anything was supposed to ever uh come of
him and zoe uh kind of fits perfectly in
the rom-com
genre you know
yeah and i think it's cool
yeah and that you get to jump into
jasper's episode which is the musical
they are all kind of a part of it but
ben for jasper's episode was there any
specific musicals that you drew
inspiration from for it
oh good question um
well on on two shots of the first song
we two shots well i think that's what's
good yeah the first one we sang that's a
it felt like a very hamilton type vibe
so me being an enormous fan of that
musical was very helpful but um it was
you know what it was it was uh me
learning that
when i'm on stage singing like trying to
emote while i sing trying to tell a
story while i sing with something new
because i'm usually just in my shower by
myself singing and i don't have to
explain anything to anybody but this one
is like you know like i'm super happy
remember this moment is me being super
happy and i'm trying to show the world
how happy i am and so it was very fun to
like play with those things but hamilton
was definitely a reference for that
first one if you remember that song
oh yeah hell yeah i could totally see
that and dude you got the move so i'm
excited for everyone to see this hey
now
sam i have to ask if you were at this
party in the show in real life who would
you have thought killed xavier
oh
oh
this is a hard question to answer ben
i'm giving it to you too so i'm going to
let you know i mean like because we
we don't know who killed in the end we
don't know
yeah
uh
you know if it was me i'd be like i
wonder what this detective is up to i
like that i like that serious curious
what about you ben
if it was me i'd say i wonder what that
kid is up to that six-year-old kid i've
watched the simpsons i watch who shot mr
burns i know kids kill people all the
time that's right
don't block out my son
like stealing candy from a baby if you
remember the simpsons episode
[Laughter]
well everybody check out what's going to
party
check out the after party this friday
it's coming apple tv plus the first few
episodes watch these two absolutely
crush it sam bend thanks for joining me
today dude you're great your energy is
awesome man so nice to meet you oh i
mean that means so much thank you guys i
appreciate it